who are you I'm Li Shan I'm looking for
my son
oh you lost your son yes many years ago
I lost my father I'm very sorry
thank you well good luck to you you too
I hope you find your son and I hope you
find your father
hey youtubers is Charlie so the first
trailer for a Kung Fu Panda 3 just
dropped so this is gonna be a breakdown
to that footage there's one very notable
addition to the cast whose voice you may
have recognized mostly you guys probably
forgot that there was going to be a Kung
Fu Panda 3 Kung Fu Panda 2 happened back
in 2011 so it's gonna be like five years
between these movies they had like like
a big post-credits teaser where you see
all these pandas like it's all about the
mystery of Jack Black's family that is
what Hollywood calls development hell
but it's actually pretty normal for
really big animated films like this to
take just giant armies of people so it's
not like making a live-action film you
can't just like turn one over every two
years the biggest thing is that bryan
cranston is playing Poe's father jack
black's father as you can see from the
trailer you know pandas not the
brightest bulb in the box
they're turning like all those funny
quirks in poe into hereditary things as
in like all pandas act like poe or at
least post father the villain is being
played by JK Simmons
so picture j jonah Jameson yelling at
Poe there was a foreign language trailer
that leaked early to YouTube but they've
since removed it they posted him he's
basically like a giant bull his name is
kaya the quote from JK Simmons just says
let's just say Kai's been away now that
he's back he's not happy about life in
general
one thing he finds when he returns is
that pandas make him particularly
unhappy so his arc in the film is gonna
be trying to get rid of that lost colony
of pandas it's been a while since the
first movie but the whole conceit is is
that PO thinks that he's the last of his
kind he thinks he's the last panda
supposedly he's looking for revenge but
we don't know what event he's
attributing to the pandas but he did
reference his character in whiplash you
know like the really angry teacher with
miles teller he said that like all the
rage that miles teller gives him in
whiplash he's now attributing to Jack
Black so like whenever he wants to get
worked up he just thinks that Jack Black
I'm actually pretty excited to see
what's going on with Bryan Cranston's
character he has played good characters
like he was a good character in Godzilla
everybody was here's Bryan Cranston and
they think Walter White so you wonder if
there's like some added layer to his
character where he's not quite good not
quite bad but I'm not expecting any
secret kung-fu skills like Poe that
other international trailer that was
taken down conveyed a lot more about the
kung-fu that goes on in the film
if you remember from Kung Fu Panda 2 it
was all about him playing with that drop
of water and then he did the same thing
with the cannonballs at the end of the
film this gets even more trippy as if
he's like bending time and space so
expect an even bigger version of a
sequence like that cannonball sequence
from the second film there's really only
a couple things you can do with sequels
you can travel inward you could deal
with like the characters emotional
journey even more or you can deliver an
even bigger spectacle I mean it's been
four years they wouldn't leave you
hanging with something like really
badass to walk away with the other
really big addition to the cast is rebel
Wilson as Mei Mei she doesn't appear in
the trailer but she plays another panda
with like really badass kung-fu skills
the only quote that rebel Wilson is
given is that she's super into ribbon
dancing and she's a funny creative Panda
she's probably gonna wind up being a
love interest for Jack Black's character
and he's a panda who learned kung fu he
didn't take a vow celibacy or anything
like that but I'm actually I'm a big fan
of rebel Wilson so this should be fun
the movie itself is gonna be released
January 29th next year in 2016 which
seems like like a weird release date but
I guess they just they didn't want to
bump up against Star Wars The Force
awakens if you ever wanted to guarantee
that people would not go see your movie
just release it on the same day as the
new Star Wars movie
so moving this to January probably
pretty smart move DreamWorks Animation
is a studio hasn't been doing so hot
financially so they're like they're
doubling down on the really big stuff so
don't be surprised when you see a whole
lot more How to Train Your Dragon
sequels Kung Fu Panda sequels like stuff
based on their most popular franchises I
was a big fan of the first two Kung Fu
Panda films so this looks like it'll be
a lot of fun for those of you asking
about inside out yes I will be doing an
inside out review this weekend so be
sure to subscribe to get that just just
like my Jurassic Park review what I'll
do is I'll I'll do like a non-spoilery
part of a video first and then the
second half of the video I'll get into
spoilers in case you haven't seen it
yesterday I did a big trailer video for
all my favorite games from e3 you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here to learn what's going on with
Game of Thrones season 6
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]